well I would say tonight went pretty
well for you guys how are you feeling I
feel great it was It's been a
good end to the week very happy indeed
yeah I agree you know this week um was
tough because it's a really hard dance
even though it's slow and smooth it's
deceptively hard and you know I had a
couple of bumpy rehearsals but it felt
like the pennies dropped during the day
today so it was good
um and then obviously you got your first
perfect score I mean you know how did
that compare to I mean you know
obviously it's not always about the
numbers but how did that feel for you
guys it felt great because we worked
really hard on the technique and all
those little details and to hear the
judge's comments and you know their
thoughts on the routine I think meant a
lot especially compared to the last
routine that we had in frame how
different it was and I feel like that
meant a lot to me so I was very very
happy with everything and then I have to
ask Michael Buble Canadian icon
obviously was the guest judge tonight
what would you rate his performance
tonight and uh how was it Michael's
great he's the Legend
um I just love his music I just been
listening to him for years I did a tour
back in 2006.
and that was for like 10 months and his
album its time was a constant in my uh
CD player so it was great great to meet
him and to dance to his music that's
awesome yeah I mean he's incredible even
just during rehearsal like he's singing
so nonchalantly it's insane he's so
talented and it was it was really cool
to watch him in person
um you know uh the last time I talked to
your mom I threw out I asked if you guys
had a bet going over you know uh who
maybe would buy somebody dinner whoever
got the highest score I just want to
know any updates they just said
um no but I would definitely like to
further that that would be great I would
love like a little present for my mom
vice versa you know whatever happens but
McDonald's yeah I'm gonna have to think
about that one
what is it like getting to be on this
journey with your mom I'm sure that's
extra special for you oh I mean it's
it's awesome I love having my mom there
you know it's just very it's always
someone to look at to be like you did
good it makes me feel good and I love
watching her especially seeing her grow
and become more comfortable each week
has been so awesome as a daughter you
know to see that confidence in your mom
it makes you want to do the same for
yourself and just be proud of her you
know
and then obviously uh lastly next week
is Halloween week I feel like that's a
pretty notorious week here at dancing
Mark anything you could tease tell us
it's one of my favorite weeks they'll
say that you know I've um
got some ideas and some tricks up our
sleeves we've got we've had lots of
ideas so we're just we're landing on one
at the moment the dance style is really
cool so just gotta keep riding the wave
you know